[MUSIC PLAYING]
SUBJECT 1: Get a good picture?
He wanted my machine gun team and
myself, the four of us,
to run across this rice paddy.
Then we're going to
give us some cover fire
to get to a certain point
way down there so we can put
a field of fire in front of
us-- a big field of fire--
to try to get them across.
And I didn't go for it.
I says to the captain, I
said, sir, I'm not doing that.
He says, I could
have you shot.
I said, no you can't.
EAMON FOLEY: War is something
that is higher energy.
War is beyond us.
War is beyond my understanding.
And so with that I'm hoping to
tell this Vietnam War story.
I'm Eamon Foley.
I'm a senior in the anthropology
department, Class of 2015.
I'm getting a
certificate in theater,
and I'm from New Canaan,
Connecticut, originally.
OK, so it all started
with dance originally.
It's the classic story--
I saw the Nutcracker when
I was six years old and
was just so enamored.
And I was like I want
to be the prince, Mom,
I want to be the prince.
And she was like oh, OK
soccer, and baseball, and all
right, but OK.
It was just kind of
a scary prospect.
After begging and
begging and begging
I finally got into dance class.
I fell in love with
it immediately.
So it started off with
Gypsy when I was nine.
And then when I was 10,
as Gypsy was closing,
I went into Assassins, which was
another Stephen Sondheim show.
And then I went on to do
two productions of How
The Grinch Stole Christmas.
Then after that I did
13, and then my last show
was Everyday Rapture,
which was amazing.
In my time at the
anthropology department
I spent a lot of time
studying ethnography
and the idea of gathering
information through interview.
And it kind of reminded
me of the Laramie Project
and all this great
theater that's
been created from ethnography.
And I thought this would be
a great way to look at where
and anthropology
and theater meet.
Over the summer I put
out some Craigslist ads.
I talked to some family members
who knew some Vietnam War vets.
I talked to my agent who was
related to a Vietnam War vet.
I talked to my dad, who
was working with one.
And I was able to just
have lunches with them
and just meet them
over the city,
and just talk about their
experience in the war.
And it was incredible.
I'm trying to work through
these and find actual lines,
actual words that
these amazing vets said
to me that can both
inform the piece
and could actually be monologue
that could actually come out
and just be straight-up
put into the show.
So right now I don't have a
script, I don't have choreo,
I don't have a cast, but I have
a lot of great ideas bouncing
around my
head and I'm really excited
to start fine-tuning them
and turning them into
physical products.
So what's really
hard for me right now
is getting words on the page.
But I was on this roll before.
I just felt like things
were coming out of me
and it was awesome.
And I was putting a lot
of time into the script
and taking a seven-
day break because you
have to write two
anthropology essays
and you have to work on this
other anthropology thesis
is-- it really kills the flow.
So I'm trying to
get back on that.
Did you guys ever
seen in my history
that I wanted to be a
director or a choreographer?
BRENDAN FOLEY: Yes, I did.
I remember, when I was
studying for the SATs--
I was probably 16, you
were 14-- we were studying
and you were tap dancing
down the hallway.
I was so angry.
[LAUGHTER]
ROBIN FOLEY: I remember when you
were taking dance classes that
you turned to me--at
I think age 7--
and said I wish I had more
dancers in this class,
and that they were better
dancers so they could do what I
have in my mind.
And that was seven years old.
So you had been
one to choreograph
for a long, long time.
EAMON FOLEY (VOICEOVER):
My greatest fear
would be that I couldn't live
up to the ideas in my head.
That this big visual feast
that I'm trying to create,
this big intense
production, would not
reach that intensity that
I'm holding it to right now.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
EAMON FOLEY: This
audition experience
was so hectic and incredible.
It was really stressful
because I wasn't sure
if I was going to get
the cast I wanted.
On the first day-- I split it
into three days and a callback.
So I'm Eamon.
I'm directing and choreographing
this little ditty.
And I'm--
When the men showed up,
I only got five guys.
Only five boys showed up.
And they were all incredible.
I cast all of them.
They're all dear
friends of mine.
And then the next
day were the girls.
And oh my god, the girls-- the
female dancers on this campus
are amazing.
And we had 16 girls show up,
which is kind of bittersweet.
It's great that I had
the cream of the crop
to choose from already.
But also it's going to mean
cutting a lot of friends--
I cut a lot of friends.
I have to send out nos.
I'm waiting for confirmation
for all my yeses,
but then I'm going to have
send out some nos, which
is going to be sad.
So I cast Alex
Quetell as Claude,
who is this kind of lost
boy character who's thrown
into the war-- who's drafted.
And he finds this
love for it there.
He's kind of lacking passion,
but then in this highly intense
place finds this manhood in
him that is exciting and scary.
This animal that he is-- there's
that addictive quality of war
that he really falls into.
And also, in this strange,
highly intense place,
he develops a relationship
with Tony, who
I cast Colby Hyland in the role.
And Tony is this poet soul.
Beautiful guy--he's removed
himself from the ra-ra nature
of the Marines.
He hasn't quite given
into it because, I think,
he's always felt like an outsider.
He's a closeted homosexual.
However, they're on a mission
together, and in that world
he's able to experiment
with that side of himself.
This is a high-stakes situation.
He mutilated her.
We're supposed to be
protecting these people.
We don't even see
them as people.
EEAMON FOLEY: But at home
he has this girlfriend,
this incredibly passionate
hippie queen organizer,
public speaker, Sheila.
I've cast Kamber Hart
to play the role.
And she's so wonderful
because she also-- she
has aerial experience, more than I do.
She's incredible on the silks.
So I'm really excited to
see her play the Red Angel
and come down on those giant red
silks and just rock that role.
EAMON FOLEY: Yeah, so this is a
work in progress on the script.
This is, I think, third
draft of the script so far.
This will be the first time
I'm actually hearing it
out loud with actors.
So again, I'm very excited
to learn something from this.
Today I'm doing the
first reading the script.
And I have a bunch
actor friends coming in.
And this is the first time I'm
going to hear it out loud.
So I'm honestly really
nervous to hear these words
because I'm the biggest
critic of my own work.
Because you hear the
minor flaws in your lines
and the little
extra tidbits that
can bring a little monologue
down or bring a line down.
And you just hate
it so much rather
than just being able to
bounce over it and move on.
So I'm nervous about just
cringing for the next two
hours of this reading
but also very,
very excited to hear
it for the first time
and learn about
the next directions
for where the show has to go.
SUBJECT 2: What's going on?
SUBJECT 3: I've waited for
this day my whole life, son.
The day you become a man.
SUBJECT 4: We love
you so much honey.
SUBJECT 3: You're going
to make us so proud.
EAMON FOLEY: So
all together, it's
a huge cast for a
show at this school.
It's 23 people.
Which is a lot of people who
are already very, very busy.
And they're going
to be giving me
a lot of their time, which is
both awesome and generous--
and I'm very excited about
it-- but a little scary
because I know it's going
to be a lot of conflicts
we're having to work around.
Especially that tech week when
I need all 23 people in a room,
and all 23 people already
have their own schedules.
It's going to be interesting.
It's going to be a challenge.
I don't know, is it worth it?
I've talked so much of this show
without Kristin here so far.
I wonder if it might just
be better to just pretend
she's not in the show.
It ruins all of our pyramids.
I cast 16 so that all
these things could happen.
All these stage pictures.
Ah, I hate this.
God, casting this is rough.
I sent out a feeler
for a lead singer.
I asked him if he wanted to do
a work session with Vince and I.
And I got back, Hey Eamon,
thank you for considering me
for this, exclamation point!
Unfortunately , I'm incredibly
behind on my own thesis at this
moment, so I can't take
on any more commitments.
I've gotten this email
back a million times.
I do appreciate
the offer though,
and would love to work
with you in the future
if you ever need a singer.
In the future?
I'm done here, this is it,
this is the last chance.
Hope the show goes well, and
can't wait to see you then.
Best, Casey.
Thank you Casey.
That's the end of Casey.
OK.
Who's next?
[MUSIC PLAYING]
SUZANNE AGINS: One of the things
that Eamon is really
struggling with right now
is his vision is enormous,
and ambitious, and exciting.
And there is no way that
we at the Lewis Center
can spend a half
a million dollars
to give Eamon all the
bells and whistles
that he has dreamed up.
Every amazing thing
he's ever seen he
wants to include in this event.
And it's simply not feasible.
So one of, I think,
Eamon's major challenges
is going to be
how he can realize
this incredibly ambitious,
wildly creative,
idea without going over budget.
We cannot accommodate
every request.
There is a lot of contemporary
stuff in the play.
Like there's a lot
of anachronism.
That makes me
think-- that I keep
going, Wait are we in Vietnam?
I'm pretty sure
we're in Vietnam.
And then I'll hit something
else and be like, Wait,
is it the '80s?
So what I would
say is, if you're
thinking about re-naming
them, look up common names.
EAMON FOLEY: I did.
I did '50s names last night.
Where I’m at right
now is Phoebe for Sheila.
I don't know.
I looked up hippie
names, because I
imagined that her mom was
a little ahead of time
for the '50s.
Um, yeah.
SUZANNE AGINS: So then I
would look up the hundred least
common names in 1953.
EAMON FOLEY: Ok,
so that's a good--
SUZANNE AGINS: Do
you know what I mean?
They don't have to be
the top hundred names,
but they have to exist.
EAMON FOLEY: Claude and
Sheila has to change.
So I have to find some names.
Which is hard because they've
been Claude and Sheila
for a year now.
And so I'm still doing a lot
of rewrites in the script
and I'm working on a
fourth draft right now.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
So this is the
Matthews Acting Studio
in 185 Nassau, the
Lewis Center's building.
And this is my favorite
space on campus.
I'm excited to really
climb around, really
turn it into a jungle gym.
But keep it in this kind of
shiny, black, sexy, still rock
and roll world.
And then have the
Vietnam come from that,
rather than go from the
Vietnam world into the rock
and roll world.
And then other cool aspects
that we're looking to do
is, right in the
center of this space
we're looking to
have a fly system.
So then it goes up and down.
So that way we can connect
other-- when it comes down it's
easy to connect
other aerial equipment to it.
But also, you run with it
and it just lifts off-- boom
then you're flying
all around space.
And you have this
full circular motion
without having to
worry about the ground.
You just kind of float.
There are some points
that exist in this ceiling
already for aerial capabilities
and aerial equipment.
And what I would like-- I don't
know exactly where they are--
but I would like
to have definitely
four points for ropes.
Like a one, and two,
and a three, and a four.
Kind of like a square
around that center point.
Boop, and perfect.
Yeah why don't you
just try it low.
Then you won't
really go anywhere.
So yeah, just feel it out,
how you're going to roll.
One, two, land.
So the Matthews is not
compatible for aerial dance.
That is-- and we're
going to work through it.
It's a little late in the
game, which is nerve-wracking.
Very nerve-wracking.
But I kind of have to
change the aerial vision.
So the idea is we're going
to put these trusses in.
And they will make
multiple points
bear the weight of one point.
So we can actually get
something to hang and swing in,
do gymnastic aerial
acrobatics on them-- whatever
we're calling it today.
Right now that means reducing
the show to three points.
And that's fine, I've
figured that out already.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
So it's Thursday, March 19.
I am one month away from tech.
Well, one less day than
a month away from tech.
Yeah I'm really excited.
It's been going great so far.
It's been really, really fun.
I love being in the room.
I love working with these guys.
What I feel like has to give
is-- it's really time for us
to become more than a group of
dancers and actors in a room.
It's time for us to
take that next step.
And I feel like we're on the
verge of getting to that very
cohesive place, where we can be
more than Princeton students,
but a squad.
An actual squad of Marines.
And so that's what
this week is about.
So it's spring break right now,
which-- and I called the actors
here, and we have most of them.
CLARK GRIFFIN: I think
we need to-- one thing
for me is holding character.
I've struggled with
keeping character up
throughout a long
period of time.
So being a soldier
throughout the whole thing,
you can't be like, Oh I'm
a soldier, go off stage.
EAMON FOLEY: Yeah.
CLARK GRIFFIN: You can't
get into character,
you have to be the character.
EAMON FOLEY: Yeah you have
to live it and figure out
what it is.
It's definitely journey,
it's going to take a while.
I understand it's
going to be a process.
And it's a process
that we've kind of
had to get some
numbers up and running.
But I guess now's the time where
we can really, really let that
be-- as we choreograph,
let that character be
in the forefront of the
brain the whole time.
CARSON HUGHES: It
is hard to imagine
in a specific rehearsal,
we're doing this one piece,
but it comes right
after something else,
and right before something else.
Doing that together.
I think just-- again what Clark
was saying about the acting
characters stuff-- I
think at least some of us
aren't that familiar with that.
So that's the scariest part,
the least comfortable part.
EAMON FOLEY: These
men were brought
so low so they could take
command out on the field.
They have to be-- you
guys have to be changed.
It's a whole different
thought structure.
And so that's what we're going
to discover during this week.
All right, we're going to
become different people.
When we come into
these dances, we're not
going to be ourselves anymore.
We're not going to
be people anymore.
We're going to be soldiers.
It's a whole different
way of thinking.
So let's start
with some warm-up,
then we're going to
do some wrestling, OK?
[MUSIC PLAYING]
So that's what
this week is about.
This week is going to be
us wrestling each other.
It's going to be running
these rehearsals less
like rushed dance rehearsals--
which kind of just
has to happen at the school
because everyone's so busy--
but it's going to be
digging into process
and finding a way to actually
do some experimentation
to figure out how these
boys can emotionally
connect to that idea.
More than just look great
doing the choreography.
Because they look great.
VOICE ON COMPUTER:
I'm doing something
to better these recruits.
to change their lives.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
EAMON FOLEY: So we found out
that the set is about at 100%
over budget.
I was told to splice it in half.
Massive changes have to be made.
And we are one month til
opening, about one month
and two days.
It's like the 23rd.
I have no idea.
Time is just-- time is flying.
I just don't want
to-- I'm not going
to be apologetic for
having big vision.
OK, I'm going to write the
conclusion to my thesis
because that is to due tomorrow.
Not the full thing, the draft.
Most unexpected thing
to happen in rehearsal
so far was the other
day, two days ago,
my lead came into
rehearsal and she told me
that she had to drop the show.
And she told me that she
wasn't going to be able do it.
And this is about a week
and a half before tech.
Two and a 1/2 weeks
before opening.
I mean there was just
a moment of like,
Oh my god I could have to
replace the lead of this show.
And teaching someone how to
do aerial dance in two weeks.
That could be the
play right now.
KAMBER HART: I was
scared of being
the weak link in the show.
I was also terrified about
getting schoolwork done.
My junior paper was due the
Monday before the show opened,
and that was really stressful.
My adviser had asked
me to start over.
I turned into 20 pages and he
was like, We need to start over.
I was like OK, there's not
that much time, but OK.
Eamon caught me in this
moment where I was really
scared academically.
I was just terrified that I
was going to screw up the show,
and that I was going to screw
up the rest of my academics.
I got in this moment of
panic and I was like,
I don't know what to do.
And so I just came into
rehearsal 10 minutes early
and just cried.
He was very calm.
He's like, You know what?
It's a little past the
point where that's possible,
so what are we going
to do to make this OK?
And he worked with me to figure
out a schedule that could
that could let me get
my academic work done.
He was so understanding.
EAMON FOLEY: That was
a little horrifying,
but we came back
down from that ledge.
But gosh, Princeton can
be a stressful place.
Princeton- It's a
tough school to go to.
What I think is on
the top priority
right now is-- of
my work to do--
is to make sure that
these dancers are
comfortable on this equipment.
We just got it in two days ago.
It all got out for the
first time yesterday.
It's a huge new skill
that takes a lot of work.
And they have to get it
show ready in two weeks.
It's asking a lot.
Especially when they have so
much other stuff going on.
With that in mind,
it's totally doable.
But what worries me is the stuff
that I don't have control over.
And that's how the
set's going to move,
and how the set's going to work.
And when we get
that stuff in, is
it going to feed the
choreography in the staging,
and the direction that
we've already done so far.
Or are we going to have
to make massive changes.
I'm down for massive
changes, I just
want to make sure
it's going to work.
It's not going to be like,
Oh we have to cut this.
Which I've heard before.
Rather than, Oh, let's figure
out creative solutions
around this problem so we can
still make this moment happen.
It kind of relies on how the
show goes, if it worked or not.
Did we get the war experience
that these Vietnam War
vets explained to me
through this production.
I can't really-- this
thesis was supposed
to be due on the 13th,
which is in a few days.
But honestly, I haven't been
doing that much work on it
for the last few days because
I'm waiting on this experience
to unfold so I can bring
that into the thesis itself.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
FRANK AFRICANO: So you can see
Luke's head looks distinctly
un-Marine-ish, so
we're going to give him
a little bit of a crew cut.
We want to make it look sexy,
though, for Eamon's show.
But yeah, we're going to
get everybody in regulation.
So that's what's going on here.
LUKE: Frank's a real Marine,
so he knows what he's doing.
FRANK AFRICANO: Not yet.
LUKE: Hopefully.
FRANK AFRICANO: But
my dad's a barber,
so there's those two
things coming together.
LUKE: It's necessary
I don't love it.
I love my long
hair, but it's fine.
It's for art, you know?
FRANK AFRICANO: You've
got so much hair.
Dude, this is all comin' off.
Here we go.
First of all, we're just
going to get this all down
to a more appropriate length.
And then we're going
to style it up.
[HAIR CLIPPERS BUZZING]
LUKE: It's really short.
But I'm into it.
Always trying to
try something new.
That's what college
is all about.
SUBJECT 6: Luke!
EAMON FOLEY: I love it.
SUBJECT 6: Oh my god.
That's weird.
[LAUGHING]
I mean, it doesn't look weird.
I mean it's weird
to see you, I guess.
It looks great.
LUKE: I feel Marine'd.
Let's go.
FRANK AFRICANO: That's
the point, right?
LUKE: Ready for the
show, let's do it.
FRANK AFRICANO: The point's
not for Luke to feel good,
the point is for Luke to
feel like he's in Vietnam.
[BAND WARMING UP]
I just feel so good.
I can't believe we're about
to put this out and show this
to Princeton campus.
This is going to blow minds.
And the feedback that
we've been getting
from the people at
the dress rehearsals
has been really,
really good too.
So I just couldn't be happier.
It takes dancers a long time
to learn how to act and tell
a story, but they get there.
It takes dancers a long time to
learn choreography, and change
it, and get into the
body of characters
that they've never had
before, and they get there.
And it doesn't happen overnight.
Right quadrant 75, wind
zero, one shot, one kill.
Send it.
The opportunities that the Lewis
Center is giving me are insane.
I mean no art is going to
be as good as the art that's
made by many minds that
are experts in their field.
Who have amazing work
under their belt,
and people who I would never
be able to get in touch
without the university.
And never be able to hear their
ideas without this university
connection.
I just know that this
is beyond anything
that I've ever done before.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
Guys, congratulations on
your first dress rehearsal.
It's awesome.
Visually, it's super cool.
We have two more, then we open.
And one of them’s the
day of our opening,
so we want to be able
to be fine for that one
and take it a little easy.
So let's start
thinking what exactly
do we need to do personally
and as a group to get
this show to the
Broadway quality
that it needs to be
on Saturday night.
Trent, you're on two.
So five, six, seven,
eight, and one two.
Cool?
Great.
So everyone's on two.
Scene at front has to keep
going and be more intense.
So I think we did it.
I think we came through and we
achieved that original goal,
which was to do something
so big and so awe-inspiring
that you can't really
wrap your head around it.
I hope the audience
comes in here
and they can't quite
think after it's done.
And that's kind of
what the best reactions
I've gone from the dress
rehearsals have been.
Just people coming to me
with their mouths open,
and just not the saying
words and walking away.
That is the war, that is--
it is too big to judge.
And too intense for any one man.
I think we've created that
intensity in the Matthews
Acting Studio,
which is really cool.
SUBJECT 7: Now everything
is coming together.
It's just feels so amazing.
SUBJECT 8: We've all
grown so much from--
SUBJECT 9: And to
trust dancers as full,
all-around performers--
SUBJECT 7: Right, and to
trust us with his vision?
SUBJECT 9: That's a lot.
SUBJECT 7: Yeah. [INAUDIBLE].
Thank you, it means
so much to him.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
STEVIE YANG: I was just really
impressed by-- number one,
all the dancers are amazing, and
their techniques are beautiful
and all that.
But more impressively,
I think their emotion
and their acting has just
really blown me away.
SUBJECT 9: Just two young
men in their physical prime,
lost in the eternal twilight
of the Vietnamese jungle,
huddling together for warmth
on a pitch-black night,
filling hours of silence
with just the sound
of each other's beating hearts.
[LAUGHTER]
Can you handle this, Marines?
ALL: Sir, yes sir.
SUBJECT 9: Good.
I'll see you on the range
tomorrow, bright and early.
PAUL FOLEY: It is a big show.
This is a full-on real show.
And I'm so impressed with
the dancers, the singing,
and how he was able to
pull all this together.
ROBIN FOLEY: He's
a professional he's
learned an awful lot
actually fighting
hard to get what he wants, so
he can produce what he wants.
And it's so impressive
on different levels.
SUBJECT 10: Tony Walker, Private
First Class, [INAUDIBLE].
SUBJECTS: [INAUDIBLE].
No one's coming to save you, GI.
No one's coming to save you.
EAMON FOLEY: What I've
learned about myself is that I
can do this in the real world.
I think I can make theater.
And I think that I can make
really big, sensory stuff even
in places where people say no.
I learned that if I
keep up that conviction,
that don't-take-no-for-an-answer
kind of attitude,
then I'm going to get
the quality that I want.
And I think we've gotten
[MUSIC PLAYING]
What's on the
horizon right now is
I want to get this show into
the hands of professionals.
I want them to see it,
I want to hear feedback,
I want to work on it, I
want to get this show up.
I think the show can't
end right here and now.
I think it has to keep going.
[APPLAUSE]